c'est le premier choix des lycéens sur
parcours sup les écoles d'infirmières
dans celle de bonnes ces étudiants qui
préparent un oral ils sont arrivés ici
il y a deux ans en pleine crise
sanitaire et pour ma part j'ai que ça à
amplifier mon envie de continuer dans
cette profession et puis je pense que
c'est aussi une bonne épreuve pour voir
aussi si on est capable de l'accepter et
puis de pouvoir d'avoir les valeurs pour
continuer dans ce métier qu'est ce qui
vous intéresse le
contact avec avec les gens le fait de
pouvoir les accompagner ça peut être les
accompagner en fin de vie ça peut être
géré des situations d'urgence trois ans
de formation
puis c'est le terrain
cette douleur particulière
amandine perrin est infirmière au centre
hospitalier de beaune elle est en
première ligne depuis le début du coc
vide c'était plus dur à gérer moralement
parce que
voilà c'était beaucoup de travail quand
même beaucoup de décès et
physiquement ça a été fatigante aussi
après c'est un métier passion donc
difficile vous pas difficile on est là
quand même des conditions difficiles et
un métier qui a parfois du mal à
recruter dans cet ehpad par exemple les
professionnels ne se bousculent pas
oui c'est beaucoup 50% des effectifs
c'est même trop c'est trop il est plus
valorisant quand on parle même le soir
ou en société de dire 20 mois je
travaille en réanimation je travaille
dans des soins très techniques comme aux
urgences ou en pédiatrie que je
travaille en gériatrie
malgré tout et notamment le manque de
reconnaissance porter la blouse blanche
reste pour tous une vocation